so
thanks for the introduction uh
all right so
i'm spike i like like you said i work at
airbnb based out of san francisco i've
been there for three years
writing javascript to ruby and i just
want to say i'm super stoked to be here
really proud uh this is such a great
event the best tech event i've ever been
to and just really happy to be a part of
it
so let's get started we're going to talk
about isomorphic javascript
and so probably if i review the first
thing i'd be thinking is wtf is
isomorphic javascript
what is this big fancy sounding word
well it's simple really the way i see it
it's just javascript code that can be
shared between different environments
so i'm mostly interested in the client
in the server i'm a web engineer so
sharing code between the web browser and
something like node.js
but as we've seen the last few days
there's a million different javascript
environments these days javascript
runtimes so you can imagine also
something like
narwhal sharing code with narwhal you
guys have heard of narwhal it's the new
java 8
javascript runtime it's a successor to
rhino
just to note there's not actually an
official narwhal logo so i thought that
was appropriate
also native platforms so android ios
these can run javascript pretty well
these days and so you can imagine
wanting to share code
between your web app or your server and
native platforms
but also things like spark and tesla
these are
we've heard about these last few days
little devices that can run javascript
why can't we share a piece of code with
those two and if you want to get really
crazy and futuristic
you can share code with your cars so i
don't know if anyone's heard of the qnk
specification
i learned about this a couple months ago
there's actually the automotive industry
is coming up with a spec to use web
technologies to build displays and cars
so like your driving directions uh your
radio air conditioning all that so but
really today we're just gonna focus on
client server
so a really high level kind of overview
of how i imagine this works is
you've got some code that runs in the
client side you've got some code that
runs on your back end and there's some
layer that's shared between the client
and server
so there's certain things that would
only exist in the client side certain
you know user interactions logging
whatever
and your back end could be
node but it could be ruby or python or
you know php whatever the idea is it's
just a persistence layer and an api and
then there's this shared layer between
which can be run on both sides and this
could be views so templates or
components or view logic whatever it
could be application logic so models or
whatever arbitrary logic and
it could be routes for example but by
the way the timer hasn't started so i'm
just going to
keep going forever
so let's talk about briefly the
etymology of the term isomorphic
javascript
so
just to be really pedantic here's the
dictionary definition of isomorphic
corresponding or similar in form and
relations
right that makes sense
so if we look at the latin forms to be
further pedantic iso means same and
morph means form so same form so
code that can share
a form between these different
environments but really we've got to
give credit to charlie robbins for
popularizing this
is the first time i ever heard of
isomorphic javascript was in his blog
post scaling isomorphic javascript code
back in 2011 so charlie is uh index zero
on twitter he's one of the founders of
ninjutsu and he's got a great blog post
kind of describing the different mvc
versus mvvm versus mvp uh patterns and
how it could apply to isomorphic code
but when i when i first started talking
about i swore for javascript i released
a blog post last year and on hacker news
most people were saying you're using it
wrong like isomorphic comes from
mathematics or it's a chemistry term or
it's this or that and they're saying
really what you mean is monomorphic
or actually heteromorphic is more
appropriate for what you're describing
or homomorphic is more correct or
polymorphic and i'm going to say i don't
like whatever it's a word um you can
refer all questions to charlie robbins
there's some more
playful trolling as well i don't know if
you know deesha he might be in the
audience today but uh he he likes to
make fun of you whenever i use that term
he calls it a five dollar word
and every time i say it he finds me five
dollars in virtual currency
and so
by the end of today i'm gonna owe him a
couple thousand dollars
so
just as an introduction let's let's look
at some apps that are using
this approach today and then we'll dive
into how you can build isomorphic apps
so a great example is flickr i don't
know if you've seen the flicker redesign
recently after they were bought by yahoo
but this is their photo page so this is
like you you search for silly cat and
you get this this list page and then you
click on one of
one of these and it's re-rendered in the
client side right it's like a single
page app client-side app whatever
re-renders but the cool part is if you
were to refresh either this page or the
previous page it would all come rendered
from the server
so each page can be rendered fully on
the server
or can be rendered in the client side
and flickr does this using yahoo's mo
down libraries i think there's some mode
down developers in the audience
from yahoo but basically it's a
collection of loosely coupled
modules kind of based around express
that lets you build apps like this and
it's a successor to mojito mojito was
yahoo's really ambitious
large
project that that attempted to build the
isomorphic apps it's something that they
used internally a few years ago but it
never really caught on more broadly
because it's so monolithic and it's very
yui ish
so instagram is another cool example
you might not have realized this but
instagram.com is all built using react
and if you land on someone's instagram
page it would be rendered on the server
side you click on
a photo would be under client side you
refresh rendered server sides same thing
and so this was built
using facebook's react library
someone mentioned earlier today react
can be executed both on the client and
the server on the server it emits html
on this on the client it emits dom nodes
but what's really interesting about this
case is instagram.com is a django app so
it's written in python
and they used a node service running on
the web on the python box and
you would hand it a template and some
data and it would come back at you with
some html but there's an asterisk here
because
instagram.com no longer uses this they
disable the node process from what i
understand it's because they there were
a bunch of python developers didn't want
the overhead of maintaining the node
service but
it's possible
another example i have to plug airbnb
this is our mobile website m.airbnb.com
same story
server rendered
but it's also a
single page app so as you navigate
around it's re-rendered client-side and
so
we developed a library called render
based off of this experience
and render lets you
take a backbone app and pull it down to
the server side and run your your models
and your views and your templates on the
server using express but it's also a
full client-side app
and one of my favorite examples is asana
has anyone heard of asana it's a really
awesome task management uh project
management app and it's all real time
and super advanced and stuff but what's
really special about asana is it takes a
different approach than these other
things that we've seen the entire
application runtime is synced between
the client and the server
so
they've spent a couple years in r d on
this and what they come up with was a
system whereby every single user session
has a corresponding javascript process
on the server
a dedicated process on the server for
every user session and as the user
navigates around in the app
those those actions are synchronized to
the server side and the server side will
compute all the same stuff it'll execute
the views and it'll fetch data and and
do all the same stuff it throws away the
html what it wants is the state so they
have got they've got a full picture of
the application state on the server side
as it exists on the client side and it
enables some cool stuff
now
this took them a few years we can't all
do this because
uh
we're not all founded by the youngest
billionaire in the world asana was
founded by one of the facebook
co-founders
and so they they had a bit of a runway
to work with
but for the rest of us we can use meteor
so in many ways
i see meteor as a
kind of an open source
take on what asano's building
and from what i understand a few of
their engineers used to work at asana
and they brought over some of the
concepts but i'm sure most of you have
heard about meteor by now but it's a
real-time app framework
and it does some really cool stuff with
sharing code between client server
so
why would you go to the trouble of doing
this
there is some trouble you got to jump
through some hoops to share your code
properly
so the first thing for me in my opinion
would be performance
and this applies mostly to the cases
like flickr where you're rendering the
whole page on the server side even
though it's a single page app now that
that comes from the the initial page
list speed is so much faster and it
feels so much faster because you're not
waiting on all the assets to download
and fetch and initialize and fetch data
before you render the page and you might
remember that twitter used to be
client-side rendered right there's a
hash bang in the url
and a couple years ago they switched
back to server-side rendering and they
said they saw a five-times
improvement in perceived performance
so that's that's great
another reason could be seo
so many of us i'm sure have built a
single page app just to be told that and
it needs to be crawlable by a web
crawler
and if by default your entire app can be
rendered on both sides it's not really
concerned
there's an asterisk here because you may
have seen last week google
wrote a public blog post saying that
actually their web crawler has the
capability to execute javascript it's a
headless browser we've kind of known
this for a while but they've
they're explicit about it now
so it's this is less of an issue but
i'm sure there's still a long tale of of
crawlers that don't have that capability
flexibility is another one
because you can run your code on either
sides it opens up a lot of doors for
doing new things and i think that meteor
and asana wouldn't have been possible if
it weren't for this ability
and maintainability i think a lot of us
have
uh tried to share templates between
client and server for example in
different languages say in ruby or in
python but you end up duplicating either
part of the template or the template
engine or your view helpers or
at some point you're duplicating code
and that's never a good thing
so there's a number of use cases for why
you might want to
use isomorphic code
the first would be templating
i think a lot of us when we first
explore this
we look at templating we look at sharing
our code between the client and the
server and so i think of templating as
the gateway drug
to isomorphic javascript because
you start with sharing a handlebars
template or a mustache template or
whatever
but pretty soon everything that goes
into populating those templates needs to
be shared so things like
internationalization
you need to translate strings on the
client in on the server
data currency formatting
at airbnb we had a bunch of handlebars
helpers that help us do stuff like this
and once you try to share that
you know you need to you want to be able
to render that on both sides too
arbitrary application logic
that's
it could be anything right it could be
model logic or
any sort of application logic
routing
once you start sharing your view layer
between the client and server
you don't want to have to duplicate your
routes between say backbone router and
your rails app right you want to have a
single set of a single source of truth
for your your routes
model validation
how many of us have written form
validation in the client side so there
was instantaneous uh you know feedback
good user experience but then duplicated
some sort of
like form val or model validation in
your api i think that's pretty common
api interactions
a lot of times we want to make calls to
an api either a first party or a third
party api using http or some other
transport
and we might need to make that call on
the client for whatever reason we might
need to make that call on the server
but if it's all in the same language and
we can share that then there's only
there's a single
uh a single set of semantics for doing
that
and then anything else i mean whatever
you can imagine whatever is necessary
for your app your use case
potentially you could share some code
between client and server
so it's important to note that
isomorphic javascript is a spectrum
there's no one way to do it there's
there's a lot of different approaches so
if this is our spectrum
if the blue side is like the
side where you share just a few bits of
view layer or a little bit of logic
and
the pink side is the entire view layer
is shared right your entire application
is shared
your app can kind of fall anywhere along
the spectrum depending on
your use case and your ambition
and so for for this side you don't
really need a lot of abstractions if
you're just sharing like some templates
or something it's pretty straightforward
to do that but the further you go along
that spectrum
you need to build more abstractions
because the client and the server are
very different environments
you need to
abstract away those differences whether
it's like accessing cookies or
or anything and we'll get into that a
bit more
and so for some examples instagram.com
would be
would be on this side of the spectrum
where they just shared their view layer
they had a totally different server-side
technology
for their most of their app
whereas asana is like all the way that's
like the extreme
where the entire application is is
shared
i also see two categories for isomorphic
javascript code
it could be environment agnostic
or it can be shimmed
per environment
so environment agnostic code does not
depend on any browser-specific
properties like the window or any
server-specific properties
like process or request or response
stuff like that
and an easy example would be handlebars
or probably any templating library
it's just dealing with primitives
strings
arrays objects functions so there's no
reason this shouldn't be able to be
executed in any any environment that's
like a proper javascript runtime
so here we're creating a template which
is a string compiling it to a function
and executing the function getting back
the rendered html
so the other category and more
interesting category is shimmed per
environment
so these libraries provide shims for
accessing environment specific
properties
so your module can expose a single api
for use on both sides
so this could be
let's say you're you're writing like a
routing library
in the client side if you want to
see what the current page url is you
would do something like
window.location.pathname
and on the server side you'd have to
access the request request.path or
or this is
what you would do in express
and a great example of a library like
this would be super agent
so superagent is an http client library
lets you make http requests
and in this example
we're saying superagent.get so it's a
git request to some json endpoint
and dot end
and we pass in a callback
and the callback takes the response
and the response has properties like the
status code http headers
the body all this stuff and it's great
to be able to use the same api on the
client in the server so how many times i
mean
typically we use like jquery
dot ajax for our ajax needs in the
client side
and then on the server we'd use http
module or the request module or whatever
and so this is a great example of
of
a module that's shimmed per environment
and it actually provides under the hood
different implementations for the two
different environments but it exposes a
single api to the developer
so there's a few abstractions that i'll
mention
a simple one would be the user agent so
let's say you're doing something you're
writing like some mobile web app or
something and you need to
determine what platform the user is on
the client side you'd say
navigator.useragent
on the server
you actually have to look at the http
header the user agent header that's
attached to the request
cookies is a great example
if you're trying to set a cookie in the
web browser you just say document.cookie
equals and then some string some
specially formatted string
on the server side you've got to set
a header set an http header
and the header name is set cookie so you
would say response.set header set cookie
and then the cookie string
and you can imagine why we'd want to do
this on both sides like a lot of times
you need to set a cookie on the client
side in response to some user
interaction and we're constantly setting
cookies on the server side
redirects is another example
so
if you're doing a full page redirect in
the browser you'd say
document.location.href equals
and then the url or if it's a push state
application you might use the html5
history api and say window.pushstate
some arguments and then the url but on
the server side we need to do a full
http redirect response.redirect and
there's an additional complication and
that
on the server there's there's different
http status codes right so there could
be a 301 redirect or 32 redirect and so
if you're trying to build an abstraction
around a redirect in your app you need
to accommodate for those differences
so let's get to the fun part
how to isomorph
how you can build isomorphic javascript
today
so
what we're going to do together is we're
going to write a module
that that solves the cookie case that
abstracts out the setting of cookies
and provides the same api on the client
in the server
so we want to
make an api that looks like this
set cookie
cookie name the cookie value
that's it
super simple
so as we mentioned before this would
turn into
in the browser we'll turn it to
document.cookie equals
my serialized cookie string
and on the server it would be
we'd be setting up an http header
response.set header set cookie and then
this that same exact serialized
string
but it gets more complicated cookies
have additional options there's a path
you can set a domain you can set an
expiry header or
expiry
property
and so then the cookie string can look
something like this document.cookie
equals
mycookie the value you know all the
stuff and when i see that you know what
i think
i think ew like i don't want to do that
like
there's a lot of edge cases there
probably it's probably years of rfcs to
weed through and try to to do that right
so
luckily
there's a module that does this for us
already
the cookie module on npm is used by
express and connect and 108 other
libraries according to npm
so let's just use this because someone's
already written it
so npm and browserify to the rescue
we've heard a bit today about
how awesome it is to use browser find
npm in your front end code and we're
going to continue along that
along that theme
so browser fi lets you use common js
to require your modules in the browser
but more interestingly
it lets you package up your dependencies
from your node modules directory
so we can npm install the cookie module
into our into our application add it to
our package.json and then we when we do
a browser file build
that will be pulled out of our node
modules directory and insert it into our
build
so the next step is
we need to figure out how we can make a
shimmed per environment module so we're
building a little module that provides a
single api to the client the server
but there's different implementations
under the hood
and the solution is to use
the package.json browser field so
there's a little known
feature
of the of package.json and the way it
interacts with browserify that lets you
actually specify different behaviors for
browser versus server
so if this is our package.json
a real bare-bones package.json
for our set cookie
module
what we can do is we can add a browser
field here
and it takes a few different forms
so if it's a string
if it's if it's just a single file name
then it'll swap out the entire
implementation
for the client side
so it'll ignore all the rest of the code
in your package and when you browserify
that bundle
it will use the lib client.js file
instead
but you can get more fine grain too
so in this example
we've got an object
and so
you can swap out a specific file for a
different file so if you've got like a
lib node.js
module in your within your package you
can swap that up for lib client.js
and you can also swap out dependencies
so we're going to be depending on the
cookie module but let's say for whatever
reason
the cookie module worked well on the
server side but it had a quirk or it you
know tried to do something it shouldn't
and it didn't work well in the client
side well if there's an alternative
module on npm or within your node
modules
you can swap out that entire module for
a different one
and so with with this with the browser
field
we can do all sorts of cool stuff and it
opens up a lot of doors on how you
package up your modules for different
environments
so what we're going to do is we're going
to build a set cookie module i actually
already built it
you can look at the source code if you
want it's at my github page
but we're gonna we're gonna step through
it here
so this is the structure of our really
basic set cookie module we've got an
index.js which is like the main entry
point for the the node module
we've got a lib directory
and in our lib directory we're going to
have a setter directory
and that setter is going to that's going
to be the implementation that actually
sets the cookie and we've got one file
for node and one for
the
browser
and so the index.js will be the node
version and the clientjs will be the
browser version and then of course
we're using cookie as a dependency so
that's going to exist in our node
modules directory
so this is what our index.js would look
like the entry point
at the top we're requiring the cookie
dependency and then we're requiring
setter and you can see where it's a
relative path
require lib setter
and so
as i'm sure you know if you if you
require if if setter is a directory and
there's an index.js file inside of it
you can just use that semantic and it
will require that
so
by default it'll use the index.js which
is the node implementation and then all
we do here
we export our public api
it's a function that takes the name
value and an options argument
and so because the cookie string is the
same on the client and the server right
the way that we serialize that cookie
string is exactly the same so here we
can use our cookie module and say var
cookie string equals cookie dot
serialize and pass it the name value in
options
and then we hand it off to the setter to
actually set that string
so here's what the node version looks
like
libsetter index.js
so it takes that cookie string and the
options
and
uh
and what it does is
so so one thing i didn't mention is with
a node
you can't just like set a cookie right
you i mean you can't do anything with
http without the context of a specific
request or response
so that's one big difference between the
client the server and the client it's
all global right like you're only ever
dealing with one
context one user session on the server
side you've got you could have hundreds
of user sessions happening at the same
time on your server and so you always
have to inject through the
request of the response
so
the api for the server side
you would add a res a response option to
the options
argument
and if you don't supply that we'll throw
an error
but basically we're just saying
response.set header set cookie in the
cookie string
and then here's what the client version
looks like
it's pretty complicated it just
sets document.cookie
and so
in our package.json
the browser field would look like this
we're swapping out
libsetter index.js
for libsetterclient.js and this is
exactly what superagent does
so superagent actually has two
completely different implementations
for
node versus the browser
and just to highlight
if we look back at our entry point our
index.js
there's there's our require this is the
require that will be affected by that
package.json field
so in a nutshell let's how to isomorph
does it seem pretty easy so far
that's obviously a kind of a trivial
example
it's a rich topic with many ins and outs
and i encourage you to reach out about
it and we can we can dive into the nuts
and bolts
and all that but for now that's all i
have
so i want to say thank you and there's
more resources about isomorphic
javascript
at spike.technology which is my my
website
and
i it says i have five minutes so if you
have any questions
you can tweet them at me
but thanks very much
you